awan plos one plus one plus one plus one
plus one posture revient avec un nouveau
modèle c'est le one pleuvent en horde 2
on avait parlé souvenez vous montrant
mon d'année dernière le one + norns
premier smartphone c'était un changement
réel dans la gamme de par son histoire
monoplace est une marque fabrique des
smartphones avec les meilleurs spec au
tarif le plus bas ce qu'on appelle ici
le flagship killer sauf que en
augmentant sa gamme et en augmentant et
bien au niveau des specs ils ont perdu
un petit peu cet adn flagship killer ils
ont cherché à le récupérer avec one
place nord est sorti l'année dernière et
cette année sort le web place nord 2
alors il ya une gamme d'ordre qui s'est
étendue on a déjà parlé et lens part du
numéro deux du vrai numéro deux le one
blue storm 2 c'est celui là alors le web
plus lente de il ya des faussaires de
one + 9 mai détrompez vous ce n'est pas
un roi de plus mais il ya beaucoup de
différences on va donc regarder
aujourd'hui quand vous propose ce one +
nord 2 est ce qu'il est intéressant à
quel prix est ce qu'il se situait ce que
c'est une belle affaire ou pas une belle
affaire qu'est ce qu'il ya dans cette
boîte vous en fais chier parce que vous
vous n'aurez pas ces deux boîtes vous
aurez la boîte avec le smartphone
débours là je fous là bang khen parce
qu'elle est sympa et vous montre d'autre
chose
les surprises qu'on va tous regardés on
va regarder quel est le prix on va
regarder s'il est intéressant si saint
preuil sur lequel il faut se positionner
versus qu'on peut trouver en concurrence
et vous allez voir c'est super
intéressant parce que oui et bien un
concurrent c'est tellement farouche des
modèles il y en a tellement à tous les
frais que quand on voit arriver un
smartphone qui dit je suis un flagship
qui leur est bien on se demande si c'est
vrai
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout est là dedans normalement là dedans
le smartphone et la gelée ouvert jeune
boxer c'est normal il est apprécié
tester alors regardez je vous montre
rapidement ce qu'à l'intérieur parce que
c'est quand même super intéressant on va
retrouver la boîte du smartphone rien
sinon quelques instants vous avez des
coques ça vous intéresse je vois une
brosse truc assez rigolo on fait un truc
de godin donc si ça vous botte et bien
écoutez
pourquoi pas enfin ça rapidement on
regarde ce qui se passe ici alors moi
j'aime bien le design de cette gamme
nord 10 ont vraiment fait un tout très
léché mais comme à chaque fois one
fleuve qu'ils aiment bien faire des
trucs l'échelle savenas faire plaisir
donc ça c'est cool on va retrouver ici à
l'intérieur une toute petite coque ok
avec l'invitation letter qu'on a à
chaque fois ça marche on a un bloc de
charge qui est assez gros qui assez
massif et ça c'est bien c'est du 65 c de
la varde charge 65 ça y est vous avez de
la recharge 65 watts vous leur charge et
de 0 à 100 % seulement 30 minutes dont
ça s'est très très cool et très
rassurant parce que si le smartphone le
matin n'est pas bien chargé bien vous ne
prenez pas vous le branchez vous prenez
votre douche vous laver les dents est un
café vous prenez un free dont fait un
bisou à votre mère et à votre chat et
bien pas filer recharger et ça c'est
vachement bien ici à noter par contre
que vous n'avez pas de recharge sans fil
il faut le savoir 1 c'est une des
différences normal on n'est pas sur un
flagship on est sur un flagship killer
pas de recharge sans fil bon on peut pas
tout d'abord par contre est ce qui est
intéressant ici vous avez deux batteries
de batteries séparé intérieur une
première batterie de 2250 milan période
une deuxième batterie de 2150 mignon
perrin ça vous fait une grosse batterie
de 4500 milliards en paire eur tout ça
pour vous dire que la techno de charges
avaient intéressant parce qu'en fait
vous allez venir recharger et bien le
flux se sépare en deux il va recharger
les deux batteries de 2250 meilleure
paire eur en même temps ce qui fait que
la recharge est beaucoup plus rapide
dont vous optimisez avec de la recharge
65 watts et avec cette technologie de
double batterie et bien ça va charger
beaucoup plus vite et ça c'est vachement
bien bravo anne place alors après on a
toujours ce petit côté avec le câble
tout rouge tout mignon j'aime bien su
différenciant mais c'est sympa attention
il suffit d'une vraie optimisation il
faut savoir qu europe là votre chargeur
votre bloc de chars je vais dire est
votre câble qui constitue en fait le
chargeur communiquent entre eux ils se
reconnaissent
il sait que si vous prenez ce câble là
avec vous le mettez là dedans il va
optimiser la charge
vous serez pas tout le temps on charge
60 100 watts mais par contre
l'optimisation vous avez d'un point de
vue logiciel
le fait d'avoir ces deux batteries et
compagnie ça vous permet de recharger
très rapidement et ça ça me plaît et non
je suis pas en train de lui mettre une
fessée
alors on regarde on continue le dise
parce que ça ça me plaît bien vous avez
plusieurs couleurs moi j'ai un côté un
petit bleu bleu sympa bleus printanier
même si on est en été ça me plaît ce que
j'aime vraiment c'est ce module photo ce
module photo il me rappelle vraiment le
one + 9 alors ici la différence c'est
que vous n'avez pas de partenariat avec
un seul blade on va le voir et si vous
ne l'avez pas du tout c'est écrit nulle
part mais néanmoins vous avez un truc
qui est vachement sympa ya un côté matt
ici qui est très cool
il ya un côté brillant ici ou en place
et faire des smartphones ont varié alors
leur apprendre là dessus vous avez ça
qui est très sympa qui est vraiment une
particularité de one love si vous ne
connaissez pas dehors des clous moi
c'est un petit switch là je suis en
vibreur
là je suis en sonnerie est tout en haut
je suis en silencieuse dont vous êtes le
petit bouton pouvoir de switcher très
intelligemment il ya un petit crantage
on convient complètement le deviner
lorsque vous l'avez dans la poche le
bouton pour l'allumer pour l'éteindre le
bouton volume et puis pas grand chose de
plus un petit capteur d'empreintes
digitales qui déverrouille rapidement et
après le design vraiment très proche de
ce qu'on a chez one place au niveau du
wan +9 fait 189 g il est pas très lourd
franchement moi je trouve très agréable
vous prenez vous le mettez en poche il
va bien rien de bien surprenant ici vous
avez un verre corning gorilla glass 5 à
l'avant ok ça c'est cool
vous avez surtout un écran fluide amoled
c'est la même technique on trouve un
sont loin de +9 tout simplement ici vous
avez un écran de 6 43 pouces vous avez
un taux de rafraîchissement de 90 ans
alors ça c'est intéressant parce que sur
cette gamme là ils vont pas vous mettre
du 120ème il le garde pour la la gamme 9
one + 9 en plus neuf pros néanmoins vous
avez quand même un taux de
rafraîchissement de 90 ans alors
regardez vous venez ici
vous venez dans vos paramètres qui sont
situées juste la claque on clique dessus
on vient ensuite dans un fichage et
luminosité
et puis ensuite pouvait venir activé
différents trucs donc que c'est la
partie logicielle qui me plaît bien
regarder dont notamment améliorer la
netteté d'image vidéo améliorer la
netteté des couleurs de la vidéo phare
ya pas mal de petits trucs en plus qu'on
peut bien faire chez wang plus il
s'appelle pas one - il s'appelle bien
one plus donc on peut faire un petit peu
plus avec eux le taux de
rafraîchissement qui va être en 90 hier
son ok on voyait ça c'est pas mal ça
fonctionne bien ça me plaît bien
ça fait qu'on a un bon smartphone avec
une belle expérience logiciels en
l'exploit solution va en parler vous
avez justement ici votre tiroir
d'applications vous avez en tout une
partie qui est ce un port et des petites
applications récentes vous avez
emplacements de stationnement pour garer
votre voiture au keynote vous avez
lezennes mode
ils viennent vraiment optimisé et c'est
un des gros points forts de ce
smartphone qui va le différencier un peu
de tout ce que vous ayez un travailleur
c'est toute cette expérience logis
elle qui est super intéressante et qui
et différenciante pour le coup et c'est
ça qui me plaît chez au moins de place
vous pouvez venir à personnaliser les
fonds d'écran les cils et ça on se
rapproche vraiment de coloriste de hauts
postes a fait partie du même groupe a
donc il ya quand même pas mal de choses
qui sont partagés même au niveau
logiciel
donc si vous aimez la partie software de
au pot et bien et si vous aimez la
partie software de one love est barrée
dans les deux cas vous avez un truc qui
est vachement bien donc ça c'est
intéressant
vous l'avez pas dit mais c'est un écran
full hd plus on s'en doutera 1 410 pays
ratio vingt neuvième certifié agi dernis
plus avec une prise en charge du srgv du
dci p3 ou qui on passe très rapidement
là dessus la partie audio dirait mot sur
les smartphones aujourd'hui c'est un
grand classique c'est vrai là dessus
également c'est un grand classique haut
parleurs en dessous haut-parleurs
principal on retrouve partout deuxième
haut parleurs c'est en parlant de
confort vous avez sur l'avant il ya un
côté un peu déséquilibré mais comme sur
quasiment l'ensemble des smartphones sur
le marché qui propose cette
configuration est donc rien de bien
nouveau sous le soleil
ce qui est intéressant par contre ici et
qu'on retrouve sur le vin de plus neuf
et bien c'est du bluetooth 5.2 avec
différents codecs à ptx à péter xhd gars
du lda qu il ya du ac c'est la même
chose à peu près qu'on assure loin de
plus 9
là où ça devient extrêmement intéressant
c'est tout ce qu'il a sous le capot en
termes de performances
oui parce que oui la performance est ce
qu'on recherche sur un smartphone ou un
smartphone qui avance on ne peut pas un
truc qui rament un truc qu'on peut
sortir l'érable il faut y aller il faut
attendre trois heures ça s'est
relativement des temps alors vous avez
deux grandes marques aujourd'hui au
niveau des smartphones android qui se
partagent le marché ya qualcomm qui est
le leader incontesté qui est sûr le plus
haut de gamme et puis vous avez
médiathèque qui est là et qui continue
sa progression et qu'on retrouve ici
avec un dilemme city c'est le dilemme
city 1205 gérer l'aide la 5g son
smartphone 5g de toute façon ça temps
c'est normal en 2020 en avant des
smartphones 5g je ne comprendrais pas
qu'on aux smartphones qui ne soit pas 5g
bien se dit même si team 1200 c'est
compliqué mais non il fait à il le fait
bien
il vous fera tourner beaucoup de jeux du
playstation n'ira pas aussi loin c'est
normal que ce soit pour retrouver avec
un one plus tough normal il tourne avec
le plus gros soc de qualcomm c'est le
seul dragon 888 ici ce n'est pas le cas
néanmoins le choix qui a été fait ici
est assez malin il ya une très belle
maîtrise
au niveau du travail de conception qui a
été fait ici ce processeur marche bien
ce qui nous permet d'avoir un bon
rapport qualité prix allant
un truc qui est intéressant et c'est ici
qu'on y resituer les tarifs le tarif il
est là il est écrit ici vous avez 2
confie de 828 ou 12 256 mo ça on en
reparle dans quelques secondes
vous êtes à 399 euros pour le 8 +128 et
vous êtes à 499 euros pour le 12 plus de
250 millions qu'on va partir sur la plus
grosse config a quasiment 500 euros dans
les faits ça marche ça marche bien ça ne
lave pas ça ne rame pas la différence
elle va également se faire au niveau de
la technologie drame ici vous êtes sur
la lpddr2 4x pas de l'ipad et diar 5 et
le peu dernière 5 c'est ce qu'on a là il
ya cinq ans d'humala force à gerland qui
fauche couche qu'ils ont c'est ce qu'on
retrouve sur le wan +9 et shaone plus
neuf pros et si vous invitez que nous
qu'on retrouve dans tous les smartphone
milieu de gamme sans aucun problème la
pédiatrie ça marche bien
vous avez le choix entre huit ou douze
il ya drame par contre au niveau du
stockage vous êtes sourd muet face 3.0
qui est rapide en lecture et en écriture
donc ça ça fonctionnera parfaitement
bien à savoir qu'ici par contre le
stockage et non extensible n'espérez pas
mettre une carte micro sd pour augmenter
votre stockage ça n'existe pas ça
n'existe pas plus avec le one piece 9 c
est eux pas plus avec le web post 9 pro
ça n'existe pas non plus si avec le one
+ 9 2 points qui est intéressant c'est
ce que vous allez retrouver ici sous le
capot au niveau de la photo vous avez un
grand-angle alors votre grand temps que
c'est votre caméra principale c'est le
même capteur que vous avez sur l'ultra
grand tante yvonne plus neuf pros alors
on va éviter de tout confondre
je veux très rapidement vous avez un
grand temps donc 150 mégapixels et ouvre
à f 1.88 nous avons un ultra grand temps
que c'est un 8 mégapixels qui ouvre à f
2.25 un champ de vision de 119 7 degrés
oui s'il vous plaît puis un petit
capteur ici monorail note de 2
mégapixels couvre f 2.5 et une caméra de
5 filles hop là les caméras celles
fixées à l'avant c'est normal c'est du
sel fils et planck est juste là et bien
là c'est du 30 2 mégapixels couvent rêve
2.45 je vous le donne dans le mille ici
vous faire des photos un peu
classiquement on va pas aller chercher
des photos nues on va pas les chercher
des choses compliquées parce qu'on est
sur un smartphone à 400 500 euros donc
c'est pas ici qu'on aura les meilleurs
rendus au niveau des photos nues et même
si à minuit même si vous pouvez poser
sur un trépied
même si vous avez une stabilisation
optique sur votre capteur principal
c'est pas un smartphone qui va être
optimisée pour les photos nuit c'est
pour ça qu'on va pas forcément les
chercher
regardez néanmoins ce qui nous sort
lorsque vous avez un très beau temps et
ce qui est le cas ici
dans l'ensemble c'est pas mal sur le
capteur principal que dès qu'on passe
sur le trac en tant que c'est beaucoup
plus terne premier petit point un petit
peu négatif en haut à droite héros à
gauche voyez on
sur les arbres il était extrêmement
poussif il ya une espèce de côté un
petit peu faussement orange et qu'on va
retrouver ici
déjà vous allez voir sans capteur
principal ce qu'on va retrouver c'est
beaucoup de saturation et impliquer un
peu exacerbé
on va retrouver un petit peu trop de
détails ça cherche à flatter sa cherche
à donner un rendu un peu plus beau quand
vous regardez sur un smartphone mais sur
l'ordinateur tout de suite c'est un
petit peu moins ces histoires le de
rendre la mariée un peu plus belle quand
vous passez sur votre ultra-grand-angle
je vous dis tout de suite c'est un peu
plus tard mais ça marche un peu moins
bien il a fallu faire des choix
forcément s'en doutera ici on voit très
bel appareil photo il faut aller sur le
wan +99 bonne plus neuf pros on peut
venir ou mais un petit peu en x 2 on
peut se rapprocher encore un peu plus
fort c'est du foie ceinture va jusqu'aux
os x 10 alors très clairement le x 5 x
10 on va oublier c'est vraiment si on a
envie de voir ce qui se passe au loin
mais globalement le rendu est pas
terrible terrible le x 2 on peut venir
croquant peut venir jouer un peu dans
l'image on a pas que tu aies l'objectif
donc on va pas aller bien loin et même
la caméra de saïfi à un rendu qui est
convenable c'est tout ce qu'on attend
d'un smartphone à 400 500 euros ici vous
avez une double carte nanosims 5g vous
avez du nfc pour le témoin de
matérialiser par contre vous n'avez pas
de certification ip pabx ip 67 pas dit p
68 point de presse a mis beaucoup de
temps à l'intégrer sur ces flagship donc
sur un smartphone comme celui là rien de
bien surprenant c'est une question de
coût en fait une question de coût à la
fabrication
ils cherchent à faire des économies pour
ac le plus concurrentiel possibles dont
convient pas vous rajouter ici de
certification qui coûte à peu près entre
20 et 25 dollars par appareil le design
est sympa la prise en main est bonne
l'expérience globale est plutôt bien il
va pas venir vous surprendre néanmoins
si vous cherchez un smartphone de one
pluzz que vous aimez wyplosz que vous
aimez la marque pour un prix à un peu
moins de 400 euros ou un peu moins de
500 euros
il faut compter sur lui moi être
extrêmement transparent je trouve bien
positionnés en termes de taille
je trouve bien positionnés en termes de
spec qu'il nous convainc bien il ya des
choses qui sont un peu en dessous mais
dans l'ensemble il est cohérent
il est cohérent mais il est cohérent
comme le sont beaucoup comme sont
beaucoup de smartphones aujourd'hui je
veux dire il ya un marché qui est
tellement énorme ya tellement de
référence il ya tellement de beaux
produits
donc la question qu'on va venir se poser
ici c'est non pas est ce que ce produit
est bien fini non pas est ce que ce
produit fonctionne bien
il fonctionne pas plus mal qu'un autre
il fonctionne pas mieux qu'un autre qui
ont des petites différences mais dans
l'ensemble ils sont cohérents ils sont
tous cohérent la vraie différence va se
faire ici
de l'expérience utilisateur au niveau de
plusieurs choses est ce que vous voulez
un petit bouton là pour venir passer en
mode vibreur en mode silencieux ou alors
à rabat sonnerie ça c'est un petit plus
et on retrouve que chez one plus donc ça
pour le coup c'est intéressant
est ce que vous aimez l'expérience
logiciel oxygène l'ouest qui est
vraiment intéressante également il ya
des petits points de détail qui fait
qu'on va adhérer à une marque on va
adhérer un modèle ou pas ce qui va être
aussi intéressant c'est ce design est ce
que vous aimez ce module photo comme ça
moi j'aime bien parce qu'il ressemble
vraiment owen plus l'oeuvre qu'on va
trouver sur deux gammes différentes en
plus sauf à +9 pro et one + knocking à
ma part et bien malgré tout il ya une
continuité et donc ça ça me plaît bien
voilà donc cesser tous ces petits points
tu as qu'il faut prendre en
considération puisque pour être
extrêmement transparents les smartphones
aujourd'hui se ressemblent tellement que
c'est compliqué de faire son choix le
petit plus en plus de one love c'est
bien c'est l'expérience logiciel que je
trouve vraiment très très bonne
l'arbitrage qui a été fait au niveau du
design et très bien l'arbitrage qui
était faux niveau de la performance est
aussi corey vraiment bien donc on va sur
cette idée du flagship killer mais
aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression cette idée
de flagship qu'il en existe plus parce
que les gammes sont tellement variés
tellement large que fectivement vous
avez les hauts de gamme vous avez très
haut de gamme vous avez le haut de gamme
dans le milieu de gamme vous avez le
moyen de gamme dans le milieu de gamme
où les bas de gamme d'un milieu de gamme
qui vous avez bas de gamme est clos de
gamme dans le bas de gamme à cannes a
tellement à tous les prix c'est
compliqué maintenant la question c'est
est-ce que vous avez 400 euros est-ce
que vous avez 500 euros mais est ce que
ce smartphone eawag pour les marques et
en appelant commentaire moi je trouve
intéressant sur ceux des gros bisous la
mort le soin de vous et puis qu'est ce
que je vous souhaite de bonnes vacances
j'espère bien de bonnes vacances
parce que les vacances on les a mérités
et ça c'est vrai des bisous tôt